Стандартний набір спецзасобів поліцейського для протидії порушникам.
Плюс додатковий спецнабір, призначений для роботи власне в умовах сільської місцевості,
де жодних інших служб порятунку може і не бути.
Спеціально під проєкт "Поліцейський офіцер громади" виділили помпову рушницю. \
Ще в нас є бензопила, яку нам видала Нацполіція  для того, щоб, приміром, їдемо, побачили, що дерево впало, перекрило дорогу.
Набір інструментів і пневмоножиці  для перерізання замків, дротів, якщо раптом нам потрібен швидкий доступ.
31-річний капітан поліції Іван Компанець нещодавно отримав усе це оснащення разом з новим автомобілем.
Він зі своїм напарником є одним з майже 600 поліцейських нового формату.
Нацполіція з 2019 року впроваджує проєкт "Поліцейський офіцер громади".
Мета - забезпечити усі ОТГ поліцейськими, які будуть працювати виключно на території громади.
Іван та Станіслав пройшли відповідне навчання, конкурс і заступили до роботи в Гребінківській ОТГ на Київщині.
Вони мають обслуговувати 9 селищ та 2 хутори.
Коли чоловіки приблизно три місяці тому розпочали роботу, вони одразу отримали купу заяв,
скарг сусідів один на одного і на владу, які не розглядалися роками.
Що трапилося? Та ну, завдовбали ці машини!  Я хочу написати заяву на дорожників.
Вони пообіцяли, щоб "поліцейського" поклали на асфальті. Бо діти ходять в школу і поворот!
Машини літають і бувають аварії. І тоді автомобілі та маршрутки їздять через мій паркан!
Поліцейський громади заспокоює жінку, мовляв, її скарга не перша, заяву писати не треба,
бо він вже ініціював заміну дорожніх знаків на рівні керівництва ОТГ.
Контакти поліцейських є у відкритому доступі, аби мешканці в разі чого могли оперативно викликати підмогу.
Поліцейські вислуховують заявників в своєму кабінеті, а також стежать за чатами, фейсбук-сторінками селищ,
аби бути в курсі подій і вчасно реагувати.
Буває, викидають таку інформацію, яка нам невідома.
Викрали велосипед.
Було декілька випадків, що людина цю заяву не писала, ми просто знаходили ці велосипеди і віддавали.
Головні скарги в українському селі - це дрібні крадіжки, насилля в сім’ї, особливо на тлі вживання алкоголю, та земельні війни.
У цьому питанні поліцейські теж мають бути обізнаними.
Питання землі - це взагалі не проблема.
Ми допомагаємо людям, залучаємо земельну службу, вони просто відбивають межі їхніх ділянок - і раз і назавжди вирішується їхнє питання.
І я помітив таку тенденцію: хто саме більше воює із сусідами і хто постійно скаржиться, ті зазвичай не праві.
Тому що вони залізли на межу сусіда і заявляють, що сусід заліз до них.
Поліцейських офіцерів громади наділили широким спектром повноважень.
Вони можуть працювати з дітьми як ювенальна поліція.
Ми приїхали, вони вирішили прибрати все, що валялося на підлозі. Двоє дітей в селі живе. Мама вживає алкогольні напої. Вони не доглянуті, вікон немає…
Також поліцейські мають виписувати протоколи про порушення правил дорожнього руху, оформлювати ДТП,
перевіряти те, як власники зброї її зберігають, тощо.
Робота поліцейського громади дуже схожа на роботу дільничного.
З тією різницею, що дільничний мав обслуговувати 15 тисяч людей, а поліцейський громади - лише шість тисяч. І забезпечення краще.
Мені дали автомобіль, на якому я можу поїхати в будь-яке місце на території громади.
Я можу реагувати на виклики. Телефонує бабуся, яка просить, мовляв, приїдьте, мені потрібна допомога.
Дільничний не міг це робити. Тому що в нього не було ні авто, ні часу займатися цим.
Відповідно до умов проєкту, в ньому можуть брати участь лише ті ОТГ, які підтвердять свою спроможність забезпечити потреби поліцейських:
пальне, ремонт та обслуговування автомобілів, оснащення усім необхідним поліцейських станцій.
Івану та Станіславу з цим пощастило. Для них станцію створили в приміщенні нового Центру надання адміністративних послуг ОТГ.
З душем та кімнатою відпочинку. Це таке нове в принципі...
У нас хлопці, які раніше працювали дільничними, дивуються, що, мовляв, у вас є душ? У вас є кухня?
Голова ОТГ Роман Засуха дуже хотів, аби його громада взяла участь у цьому проєкті.
Він сам - учасник АТО, тож розуміється, які поліцейські потрібні громаді.
Роман Засуха особисто брав участь у відборі кандидатів на посаду поліцейського офіцера громади.
Буквально не міг дочекатися, коли вони з'являться.
Приміром, раніше мусив сам розбирався, хто із селян влаштовує стихійні сміттєзвалища на околицях.
А тепер разом з поліцейськими провів ціле розслідування.
Спільно ходили, шукали таке сміття, з якого можна вилучити інформацію.
Люди залишають чеки, ксерокопії паспортів, флюорографії.
Такі поліцейські хитрощі дають результат.
Людина навіть не підозрює, що її можуть знайти.
Кількох людей примусили прибрати своє сміття, кілька сплатили штрафи в бюджет громади.
Решту сміття вивезли на законе сміттєзвалище.
Гребінківська ОТГ також оголосила боротьбу незаконним вирубкам лісу.
Відкриті вже 2 кримінальні справи.
На допомогу поліцейських громади голова ОТГ сподівається й у вирішені ще однієї екологічної проблеми.
Кілька років тому, ще до створення ОТГ, тут перекрили русло річки ось цією дамбою,
можливо, в інтересах мисливців, щоб їм було зручно полювати на диких качок. Голова хоче її знести.
Тут цієї споруди немає по документах. Тут її пересипали, щоб зробити болота, плесо. Немає протоку води, вода стоїть та гниє. Неприємний запах.
Я попрошу поліцейських громади, щоб проконсультували, куди звернутися, щоб прибрати.
Гребінківська ОТГ підписала з МВС меморандум про співпрацю, де гарантувала матеріальне забезпечення поліцейських.
А самій громаді натомість гарантували, що призначення чи звільнення поліцейських буде відбуватися за погодженням з ОТГ.
Відповідно до меморандуму, на будь-якому етапі, якщо стосовно офіцера громади є скарги, будь-який громадянин скаржиться,
що поліцейський незаконно щось робить, поводиться негідно…
Один дзвінок в ГУ - і цього поліцейського забирають.
А іншого не можуть призначити без згоди громади.
Поліцейський офіцер громади отримує зарплатню в Національній поліції, має виконувати накази свого керівництва,
але при цьому має співпрацювати з керівництвом ОТГ, від рішень якої залежить його матеріальне забезпечення,
надання житла - службового чи постійного у разі переїзду, тощо.
Щоправда, за таких умов існують певні корупційні ризики, вважає експерт з реформи правоохоронних органів Юрій Чумак.
Було б непогано, щоб на законодавчому рівні унормували цей порядок взаємодії
органів місцевого самоврядування з поліцейськими офіцерами громади.
Щоб штучно не ставилися якісь палки в колеса.
Я знаю, наприклад, в Дніпропетровській області торік поліцейські офіцери складали протоколи щодо керівників ОТГ, де вони працюють.
Немає бути такого, щоб поліцейські "заплющували очі " на тих, хто їм допомагає матеріально.
Проєкт "Поліцейський офіцер громади" мав завершитися в 2020 році.
Передбачалося, що до цього часу кожна ОТГ мала отримати свого поліцейського.
Але через пандемію діє проєкту подовжили.
Проєкт фінансувався коштами держави та міжнародних партнерів України.
Наразі в Україні є приблизно 650 офіцерів громади, ще приблизно 130 проходять навчання.
Керівництво МВС обіцяє, що до кінця 2022 року усі ОТГ матимуть своїх поліцейських
і буде розроблена уся необхідна нормативна база для поліцейських.
Іван Компанець прийшов у поліцію ще в перший набір нової патрульної в 2015-тому,
потім працював в ювенальній поліції, потім в спецпідрозділі "Миротворець" у зоні бойових дій.
Каже, що чи не вперше він отримує задоволення і від гідних умов праці, і від комунікації з населенням.
У нього з напарником поки немає проблем з  керівництвом громади і вони радо далі працюватимуть в Гребінківської ОТГ.
Тут максимально комфортні умови для роботи поліцейського.
Тут ти почуваєшся, що ти робиш ту роботу, яку потрібно робити. І забезпечення, і спілкування з громадою.
В нас є комунікація з людьми, з якими можна було створити дружні відносини.
Я даю свій телефон і представляюся, то я говорю, що я Іван, не Іван Володимирович.
Іван Компанець сподівається, що проєкт Нацполіції створить в маленьких населених пунктах
свого роду сервісні служби для населення, і люди нарешті почнуть довіряти поліції.